شهدت حقبه الحرب البارده وتحديدا في فتره
الحرب في فيتنام ظهور طائرات حربيه
امريكيه متعدده احدى هذه الطائرات تم
تصميمها لتكون مقاتله هجوميه اسرع من
الصوت والاهم ان يكون لديها قدره على
توجيه ضربات نوويه الى اي هدف في عمق
الاتحاد السوفيتي المقاتله متعدده المهام
115 تم تصميمها لتحل محل القذفه المقاتله
اف 84 اف كما انها دخلت الى الخدمه في
سلاح الجو الامريكي في العام
1959 لتكون طائره الهجوم والسيطره الجويه
الاساسيه في حرب فيتنام تم تزويد مقاتله
الاف مئه وخمسه بمدفع رشاش من طراز فولكن
متعدد الفوهات من عيار 20 مليمتر هذا
بالاضافه الى صواريخ المضاده للطائرات
هذه المقاتله كانت لديها قدره على حمل ما
يقرب من سته اطنان من القنابل والصواريخ
بالاضافه الى قدرتها على حمل قنبله نوويه
خضعت هذه الطائره لعدد من التعديلات من
بينها مثلا توسيع قمره القياده لتتسع
لتيارين وكذلك تحويلها الى طائره متخصصه
في استهداف صواريخ السام اثنين كما تم
تسليحها بصواريخ من طراز الشرايك الذي
يتتبع موجات الراديو ويدمر منصات الرادار
التي توجه صواريخ السامه تم انتاج
833 طائره من هذه المقاتله الا اسقاط عدد
كبير منها وكذلك كثره المشكلات الفنيه
التي واجهتها مثلا ارتفاع درجه حراره
المحرك وكذلك تسريبات الوقود كل هذه
الامور دفعت القوات الجويه الامريكيه
لسحبها ولكن بشكل تدريجي حتى خرجت تماما
من الخدمه في عام 1980 هذا بحسب موقع
المتحف الوطني للقوات الجويه
الامريكيه